for as long as humans have existed
there's been an impenetrable barrier
between us and the rest of the animal
kingdom a barrier of understanding and
connection the original language barrier
we've made some Headway with animals
like dogs who can understand simple
commands and there's currently a massive
Endeavor to translate whale language
into hours a subject we'll talk more
about in a future video
but when it comes down to sitting face
to face with an animal and conversing
about thoughts feelings and emotions
we've never quite bridged The Divide
however the closest we may have ever
gotten was with Coco the Western lowland
gorilla as an ambassador for her
critically endangered species Coco was
world renowned for her love of cats
friendship with Robin Williams and an
incredible ability to communicate
through American Sign Language
born at the San Francisco Zoo in 1971
Coco was rejected by her mother and
became severely ill Stanford University
grad student Francine Patterson soon
took her in to care for her and taught
her sign language as part of her
doctorate work in developmental
psychology after Decades of work Coco
developed a vocabulary of over a
thousand words Coco could reason about
the world communicate her needs and even
grieve other beings she gave us a
glimpse of what great apes could be
capable of
while gorillas aren't our closest living
relatives we share about 98 of our DNA
with them and even though our brains are
larger and more complex gorillas are
incredibly smart but if you were to come
across a gorilla in the wild your first
thought probably wouldn't be about how
nuanced and intelligent they are instead
you'd probably be telling yourself
you've had a good run of it as your life
flashed before your eyes gorillas aren't
necessarily aggressive to humans but you
sure wouldn't want to stick around to
find out because gorillas are absolutely
gigantic and monstrously strong they're
one of the most impressive examples of
remarkable intelligence meeting
Incredible strength in the animal
kingdom
gorillas are the largest of the great
apes and live in Equatorial Africa there
are two species the eastern and western
gorillas which are separated by about
560 miles or 900 kilometers of Congo
Basin Forest each species has a lowland
and Upland subspecies
they live in family groups of usually
five to ten but sometimes as few as two
and up to as many as 50. gorillas are
also defined by profound sexual
dimorphism with smaller females and
super-sized males these giant males lead
the family groups and hold the position
of Authority for years they're known as
Silverbacks due to the saddle of gray or
silver hair on the lower part of their
back and these adult males are extremely
strong an average silverback gorilla can
weigh up to 180 kilograms and can easily
deadlift over 450 kilograms two and a
half times their body weight average
humans on the other hand would struggle
to deadlift only one times their body
weight but the strongest gorillas can
lift much more than that it's estimated
a gorilla can lift 815 kilograms 4.5
times its body weight the human deadlift
record is 501 kilograms 3.3 times his
body weight so even accounting for size
gorillas are much stronger than human
and this is despite the fact that we
have a similar muscle mass to weight
ratio which is about 38 for human and
gorilla males so how are gorillas that
much stronger one reason is that the
incredible weight of gorillas is
supported by denser bones that are more
resistant to fractures and breaks bones
are made up of three different types of
tissue that each perform a different
function at the ends is subchondral
tissue which is smooth to provide
frictionless movement the hard outer
shell is made of compact tissue which is
strong and able to resist fracture and
the interior is cancellous or trabecular
tissue which is sponge-like and porous
to allow for flexibility compared to
humans gorillas cancellous tissue has a
higher density making it stronger in
addition to their bone composition
allowing for their extra strength their
bone structure does so as well like
other great apes gorillas have straight
and continuous brow ridges that stick
out over their eyes and males have
something called the sagittal Crest
which is a bony Ridge at the top of the
skull these pronounce bones provide a
more extensive muscle attachment area
which helps support weaker bones in the
skull and reduces strains when chewing
hard foods like sticks but the most
surprising thing about a gorilla's
strength is that they basically don't
eat any meat at all to get this yoked
gorillas are omnivores but their diet
consists mostly of plant matter such as
stems bamboo shoots and fruits the only
limited amount of animals that they do
consume are insects such as ants or
termites to digest and absorb nutrients
from such a fibrous food source gorillas
are equipped with an extra long gut and
their hind gut which consists of the
cecum and colon make up about half of
their total gut volume compared to just
20 percent in humans if you've ever
wondered why gorillas have a big pot
belly that's why each day they eat about
18 kilograms of food and much of this
weight is comprised of the compound
cellulose this is the fibrous molecule
that gives plants their structure and
rigidity and surprisingly this is the
secret ingredient gorillas use to get so
muscular this is surprising because
cellulose itself is just made of lots of
sugar molecules changed together there's
no protein in it humans can't even
digest cellulose it simply passes right
through us and technically gorillas
can't either at least not by themselves
what gorillas have that we do not is a
microbiome of bacteria that do readily
break down cellulose producing
digestible sugars and volatile fatty
acids these fatty acids are then taken
up by the gorilla and used for energy
and to synthesize complex molecules such
as protein so it's the bacteria in their
gut that provides them with the protein
that they need this is a process known
as hind gut fermentation and is similar
to how horses and cows digest their food
and with all this Brawn When Gorillas
decide to start throwing punches it can
get ugly when two groups meet the
leading Silverbacks can sometimes engage
in a fight to the death mainly using
their sharp canines to cause deep gaping
injuries gorillas have a bite force of 9
megapascals stronger than a lion grizzly
bear or spotted hyena but fortunately
extreme aggression is rare in stable
gorilla groups in fact these groups are
social collaborative and extremely
complex
Western lowland gorillas have to travel
to find the right food their day begins
at dawn and they set off into the forest
led by a Silverback male they eat as
they walk along and if they find a fruit
tree they'll climb its branches to get
to the fruit once they're done for the
day they demonstrate a remarkable
Behavior each gorilla builds a nest on
the ground and sleeps there for the
night by all appearances this looks like
tool use but scientists don't all agree
to understand more about Guerrilla
behavior and social structures I talked
to Dr Robin Morrison postdoctoral
research fellow at the Diane Fosse
gorilla fund The Nest is one of the most
complex tools you use it it's really
important but it's not classically been
termed as a tool but gorillas build a
nest every day and you can see that the
small ones will try and do it they're
learning and it'll be a bit of a mess
and it won't be as good so there is real
kind of skill involved involved in
building these nests and they are pretty
comfy while nest building by gorillas
might be considered tool use rather than
animal architecture in other contexts
tool use is rarely seen by wild gorillas
especially when compared to other ape
species such as chimps and bonobos in
fact because gorillas live in what some
scientists have called the great salad
bowl where their favorite foods are
plentiful for a long time it was thought
that gorillas didn't use tools besides
nests in the wild at all that is until
2005.
at an observation site in the northern
Congo scientists watched as one female
gorilla used a walking stick to test the
water depth in front of her as she waded
into a pool and another female from a
different troop used a large Branch to
balance herself as she foraged for
aquatic plants and then used it as a
bridge to help her cross a swampy patch
of land more recently in 2013
researchers watched a mother gorilla
sitting in a bamboo Thicket hold on to a
bamboo pole as her infant on the ground
below climbed up it to reach her these
researchers suggested that unlike other
ape species gorillas primarily use tools
to overcome physical obstacles rather
than to acquire food so gorillas do seem
to use tools and use them very
proficiently and in captivity this has
been observed even more extensively
Studies have demonstrated their ability
to use sticks to extract food from
various devices and researchers have
documented the spontaneous use of sticks
to attain food from Out Of Reach
locations infant gorillas learn how to
use tools build nests and other
behaviors by watching and imitating the
others in the group in particular their
mothers in fact family groups are
tightly bonded and spend evenings
grazing playing and resting together and
one of the most important factors in
this group's bonding and success is the
leader of the group the Silverback male
this was exemplified by a study carried
out to investigate how young gorillas
fared if their mothers died early in
their lives they expected young gorillas
to fare worse in life if they lost their
mother but to their surprise this was
not the case if the babies were no
longer dependent on their mother's milk
they did just fine
we think this is is mostly because the
dominant males do a lot of caring which
is also a little bit unusual in primates
so they take on a lot of caring
responsibilities they'll have little
crashes of all the little gorillas that
are kind of running around them or
climbing up on them
um and especially if there's gorillas
that have lost their mothers then they
are kind of extra caring towards them
and they might share their nest at night
with them or they might carry them when
they've got to move a long way and we
have found that actually the females
prefer males that are much more caring
towards young gorillas so it might
actually be kind of sexual selection it
might be these females that are choosing
these males that are nice towards the
babies because that then helps them you
know reproduce more too and part of the
social glue that keeps gorillas bound so
tightly is the communication they have
with one another they do so through a
variety of methods including facial
expressions such as the play face that
indicates they want to play or
well-known gestures like the beating of
their chest as a sign of aggression
mission Dr Joanne Tanner who is a former
volunteer companion to Coco studied the
gestures made by gorillas at the San
Francisco Zoo she categorized what she
observed as either a tactile visual
audible or iconic gesture she found that
gestures can be unique to a group or
even just to an individual she also
discovered that most of the time
gorillas used multiple gestures in a
sequence similar to a phrase or sentence
they also displayed back and forth
communication sort of like a dialogue
based on what she saw she surmised that
gestures are an efficient way to Foster
social relationships they improved
social interaction and even possibly
enhanced reproductive success and
gorillas are also extremely vocal there
are quite a big range of especially
vocalizations
um with the with the gorillas that we
study we we know the context they're
used in right so often when we go into
the group we'll make these kind of
grunting sounds which are we think at
least pretty reassuring that just
telling the gorillas kind of where we
are and that they're like very
non-threatening sounds and sometimes
these vocalizations sound quite familiar
one of my personal favorites is that
gorillas will often hum when they're
eating and we think it might be foods
that they kind of particularly enjoy we
may not know everything that gorillas
are trying to say but sometimes it's
easy to make a pretty good guess but
what more might gorillas be capable of
some researchers think that gorilla
communication skills don't stop there
that they may be able to speak with us
as well using our own language
motivated by the pioneering work of
psychologists Alan and Beatrix Gardner
who taught American Sign Language to a
chimpanzee graduate researcher Francine
Patterson started teaching Coco the
gorilla American sign language in 1972.
she did this the same way you would
teach a child by modeling the sign and
its meaning and molding their hands into
the correct orientation and movement and
in just a few weeks Coco began learning
to sign she learned new signs at about
the same rate as a human child and over
the course of her life Coco
spontaneously and accurately used 1100
signs at least once and over 300 signs
at least half the days of a month
observed by two independent researchers
her vocabulary ranged from basic words
like food and more to emotions like love
and sorry to Concepts like obnoxious and
fake there were some signs that Coco
herself modified she did this either
because of a limitation of gorilla
Anatomy such as having shorter thumbs
relative to their index finger than
humans or because naturally modulating
it making it bigger or faster expressed
a different emphasis or meaning she also
combined signs to represent a word she
didn't know the sign for for example she
compounded eye and hat for mask and
stuck and metal for magnet and Coco
relayed a lot more than just her wants
and needs she also communicated her
feelings revealing an empathy for other
creatures this was particularly
exemplified with her love of kittens
after repeatedly asking for one she was
given a kitten that she named all ball
she often cradled it in her arms like an
infant later the cat sadly died in an
accident on hearing about it Coco signed
cry bad frown sad
and Beyond a seeming emotional
intelligence Coco also appeared to have
the ability to lie which to scientists
was a really big deal one day she sat on
the kitchen sink and ripped it off the
wall when asked who did it 127 kilograms
cocoa pointed to a member of Staff who
weighed 40 kilograms and blamed her
scientists thought that at last they had
found a way for an animal to communicate
her own inner self her own thoughts
feelings and emotions that the barrier
had at last been broken however many
have questioned whether Coco was really
speaking through sign language or rather
just mimicking the signs as a means to
get a reward that she was doing nothing
more remarkable than what a dog does
when it's told to sit or stay that the
hand symbols she learned were empty
signifiers that she learned to piece
together to get what she wants not that
she actually knew what they meant that
perhaps she was just articulate enough
for us to project our own ideas of what
we thought she might be saying some say
Coco's sign language has been totally
debunked but others still stand by it
completely the debate has been raging
for 30 years but personally I feel like
the real truth lies somewhere in the
middle perhaps Coco isn't using language
in the exact way we do and perhaps we
can't exactly call it language but for
the people who spent decades with Coco
it was clear that she had a level of
empathy and understanding that's hard to
refute that she used phrases in unique
ways and used them to articulately ask
for the things that she needed that she
cared deeply for the people around her
that she seemed to make jokes and even
laugh at them and Coco's Legacy is still
in motion the gorilla Foundation is
currently digitizing and analyzing
thousands of hours of video footage to
allow others to build on their research
interspecies communication is a tool
that allows us to understand the minds
of gorillas in a way that leads to
better conditions for them in captivity
increased empathy for them in the wild
where they're critically endangered and
a greater understanding of the
extraordinary emotional and intellectual
capabilities of our fellow great apes
and maybe instead of forcing Coco to
communicate in a manner that was alien
to her species we could have learned
more by learning her language perhaps
maybe in the grunts and gestures there's
more there than we even realize
scientists today are painstakingly
studying the communication of wild
primates to understand what they might
be saying because who knows what they
can teach us if we take the time to
understand the world gets so much richer
and more exciting the more we understand
it from interpreting the communication
of other species to learn more about
them to dissecting genomes to trace our
evolutionary history to modeling neurons
with computers to unlock the mysteries
of the brain we're finally tapping into
a realm of knowledge that was never
available to us before
incredible things are happening where
biology meets computer science and to
stay on top of this Cutting Edge I use
brilliant
brilliant.org is the best way to learn
math and computer science interactively
there are thousands of lessons from
foundational and advanced math to AI
data science neural networks and more
all of which I've used to help me write
these videos
the computational biology course is a
particularly good place to start if
you're like me and have a background in
classic biology and the world of
computer science is new and a little
scary
it will show you how algorithms can
tackle problems like genome
reconstruction ancestry or even DNA
forensics
the course is challenging but brilliant
doesn't penalize you or impede your
progress instead they give you an
in-depth explanation to guide you to the
right answer so you can learn from your
mistakes it's easy to learn in this low
pressure environment and most
importantly it's easy to learn by doing
the interactivity of brilliant is my
favorite part I love learning new things
while moving little robots around or
interacting with sliders and levers that
really show me how things work rather
than being told in dense blocks of text
to try everything brilliant has to offer
for free for a full 30 days visit
brilliant.org real science or click on
the link in the description the first
200 people will get 20 off Brilliance
annual premium subscription and every
sign up immensely helps this channel
foreign